- In order for the audience to believe in
and be engaged by a
Shakespearean character,
they have to come across as
a real person on the stage.
Or maybe we have no error.
So you know when I read
that, when they said,
"they have to come across as
a real person on the stage,"
the way that the sentence was constructed,
it looks like they're
referring to the audience.
In order for the audience
to do this thing,
they, the audience, has to come across
as a real person on the stage.
Well that's not what
they're talking about.
They're really talking about the actors.
So this "they" here is confusing.
It could be...
Are they talking about the audience?
Are they talking about
the characters on stage?
So I would say the error
right here is in part C,
and I would change "they" to...
If I were editing this,
I would change this to "the actors."
"The actors" have to come across as a...
You need to say "the
actors" have to come across,
have to come across as real people,
or you could say "the actor."
"The actor" has to come across
as a real person on the stage.
So that would feel a lot better.
In order for the audience to believe in
and be engaged by a
Shakespearean character...
And that's good.
We're doing "a Shakespearean character,"
not "Shakespearean characters."
So that's why it's good to do
the singular right over here.
"The actor" has to come across
as a real person on the stage.
So this feels much better.
And so I would definitely say
the error was in part C.